[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres nous avons intitulé cette
émission les immoralistes on connaît
tous la formule de Gide on ne fait pas
de beaux livres avec de bons sentiments
je suis persuadé que nos deux invités
partagent cette maxime et je pense même
que il considère que c'est avec de la
transgression qu'on fait de beaux livres
et ma Becker bonsoir et ma Becker vous
avez publié il y a une dizaine d'années
monsieur dans lequel vous racontiez la
passion érotique d'une jeune fille pour
un ami de sa famille bien plus âgé
qu'elle et c'était une description très
crue
et puis vous avez publié un livre entre
temps mais en 2019 vous avez publié un
livre qui a beaucoup fait parler de lui
à la fois par les louanges qu'il a reçu
et puis par les controverses qu'il a
suscité la maison dans lequel vous
relatiez votre expérience ou votre
enquête de pendant prostituée dans deux
maisons closes de Berlin dans cette
rentrée vous revenez avec l'inconduite
chez Albin Michel dans lequel vous
racontez les aventures
sentimentales et surtout sexuel d'une
jeune maman c'est très chaud on va en
reparler dans quelques minutes et puis
Simon Libérati Simon libérative bonsoir
bonsoir les années écrivain prolixe avec
performance chez Grasset c'est votre 12e
livre on se souvient que vous aviez reçu
le Prix féminin pour un récit à propos
de Jane Mansfield on se souvient du
livre Eva ou parliez de votre compagne
de l'époque mais vous n'êtes pas
seulement un écrivain vous êtes aussi un
personnage
de la vie parisienne bronchée on vous on
vous prête l'amour des belles femmes
connues de la coupe des belles voitures
vous fréquentez à la fois les grands
auteurs mais aussi le Palace et Beck BD
bref vous avez comme ça une figure de
dandy rock'n'roll et vous du coup vos
détracteurs vous vous suspects de danser
un peu sur le bûcher des vanités vous
vous reconnaissez dans cette silhouette
ou pas du tout bah oui oui bien sûr
celui qu'on suspecte mais le reste c'est
à peu près vrai oui oui et voilà mais
bon c'est comme ça vous savez on invente
c'est Frédéric Beigbeder qui avait été
mon premier éditeur qui m'avait dit une
fois qu'on vous a mis dans un dans une
case on en sort plus on en sort plus on
c'est pas la peine d'essayer il vaut
mieux aller au dans le sens de la
alors performance performance vous
empruntez d'ailleurs le titre à un film
des années 70 dans lequel jouait Mick
Jagger qui était l'égérie des swing du
Swinging London et des Rolling Stones et
dans ce livre on passe quelques semaines
avec un écrivain
septuagénaire qui se relève d'un AVC qui
qui est un peu en panne de d'inspiration
et qui va d'un côté essayer d'écrire une
série sur les Rolling Stones et de
l'autre essayer de vivre son aventure
sentimentale nouvelle avec une sa
compagne qui est non seulement de 40 ans
sa cadette mais son ex-belle-fille rien
que ça
[Musique]
racontez-nous d'abord d'un mot parce que
ça irrigue tout le roman le moment
l'épisode de la vie des Stones sur
lequel votre écrivain cqagère dans
lequel on vous reconnaît un peu
sur lequel il veut décrire une série bah
c'est très simple ça se situe à partir
du moment où il y a une arrestation il y
a une arrestation pour trêve pour
usage de stupéfiants qui est la première
à peu près de l'histoire de la pop
musique à l'époque il y avait eu des
requaires et des jazzman mais on n'avait
pas autant parlé c'est une arrestation
ou qui se Richard et Mick Jagger ont été
arrêtés chez Keith Richard donc dans le
ce sexe et ça se passe en 67 et la fin
la fin de l'épisode qui m'intéresse pour
pour moi ça se termine en 69 avec la
mort de Bryan Jones qui était donc le
guitariste et le fondateur du groupe
mais c'est pas un livre sur ça mais en
tout cas voilà ça c'est le cas de
historique de ma de ma recherche c'est
pas un livre sur sa mais cet épisode a
une signification particulière parce que
c'est le moment disons de la
métamorphose des Stones vont devenir le
groupe
iconique mondialement connu qui sont
hors cet épisode est fondé sur une
trahison et même sur une double trahison
oui alors ce qui se passe c'est qu'en
fait ça c'est c'est la l'histoire on va
dire d'amour qui a derrière c'est à dire
qu'elle ne t'a pas Lemberg qui était
donc en fait la ça a été la bonne fée
des Rolling Stones que c'est elle qui a
présenté les Rolling Stones à Londres à
la à toute la gentry anglaise des
cadence donc les aristocrates les
artistes etc et c'est elle qui a fait en
fait en changeant le style vestimentaire
c'est aussi bête que ça mais en
changeant le style vestimentaire de ses
partenaires qui a fait qu'on est passé
du milieu de jeunes rocker un peu voilà
onglet comme ils sont pas toujours
formidables physiquement à tout à coup
quelque chose qui était très étrange qui
commençait à être vraiment androgyne etc
et c'est Anita en fait il voulait le
vestiaire d'Anita et donc ça c'était
Brian et après il y avait elle a quitté
Brian Jones pour qu'il se Richard et qui
se Richard du coup est devenu lui aussi
une sorte de d'hommes femme comme ça
après maintenant il est devenu un vieux
pirate mais avant il y a eu cette
période et voilà mais cette trahison en
effet Anita quitte Brian Jones pour
qu'il se Richard les Stone quitte Brian
juns qui était leur fondateur et cette
trahison fêtée à ce qui se passe pour
votre écrivain c'est plus à génère parce
que lui-même vit une nouvelle histoire
d'amour
fondée sur une trahison et même une
trahison au carré qui a en plus un
parfum d'inceste puisque non seulement
une quitte sa femme mais il la quitte
pour la fille de son ex-compagne enfin
il la quitte pour son ex belle-fille et
est-ce que ça signifie que pour vous
pour les Stones comme pour votre
écrivain il n'y a d'accomplissement de
bonheur de jouissance de plaisir que
dans la transgression que dans
l'affranchissement des règles morales du
bien et du mal j'ai pas de règle de
conduite ce qui s'est passé c'est que si
vous voulez dans ma vie très souvent
j'ai remarqué que les que les
les événements traumatisants
traumatisant pour moi ou pour mes amis
et mes proches étaient entraînés
un regain d'activités artistique donc
voilà mais je l'ai pas cherché si vous
voulez je cherche jamais les choses ça
m'est arrivé et donc ça m'est arrivé
dans ma vie en effet un épisode qui est
à peu près ce que vous venez de de de
dire et donc voilà et c'est ce qui m'a
en effet permis d'écrire ce livre avec
peut-être une énergie que j'aurais
peut-être plus si je comme vous le dites
je suis un polygraphe si ce n'est un
Kako grave et donc j'ai écrit beaucoup
et j'ai mon 13ème livre en fait je vous
ai pas relevé tout à l'heure mais c'est
mon 13ème livre le chiffre est important
et donc voilà donc j'ai besoin de me
j'ai besoin de me relancer alors après
voilà c'est très égoïste les les
écrivains donc voilà j'ai fait ça mais
il y a il y a une dimension autre qui va
au-delà de l'égoïsme c'est à dire que je
pense qu'en effet il y a une fracture il
y a quelque chose mais c'est pas là
c'est pas la transgression en soi voilà
c'est une situation qui qui amène à un
acte d'écriture ce qui est assez amusant
c'est que votre votre héros votre
écrivain il a été rockeur enfin il a été
révolutionnaire disons dans les années
70 et là il est assez réac enfin il aime
pas les pop moderne peut-être parce que
c'est une époque dans laquelle il est
plus très jeune mais par exemple vous
racontez c'est très très drôle
d'ailleurs c'est très joli mon écrit on
s'amuse vous raconter ces démêlés avec
les produits que les jeunes producteurs
de la plateforme on imagine que c'est
Netflix avec lequel il essaie d'écrire
racontez-nous ça parce que c'est amusant
c'est quoi le cœur blanc le profil du
jeune producteur aujourd'hui ils sont
très gentils ces garçons c'est en
général des HEC intelligents quand une
certaine culture mais qui ne va pas
au-delà de de des années récentes on va
dire
ça remonte au plus tôt au plus haut à la
nouvelle vague et encore et donc ils
sont voilà et donc ce garçon mon héros
qui a 71 ans se retrouve super révolté
c'est juste voilà il se retrouve à
devoir écrire avec ses gars qui ont
35 ans qui sont père de famille qui sont
ce qu'on appelle des bobos maintenant
enfin j'aime pas le mot mais bon voilà
et donc voilà donc lui évidemment c'est
c'est cette confrontation aboutit à des
mais moi c'est ce qui m'est arrivé dans
ma vie en fait je veux dire à chaque
fois j'ai travaillé dans le cinéma ça a
été une catastrophe et non pas et j'ai
eu des castings différents selon les
époques mais ça a toujours été un peu
difficile parce que voilà parce que il y
a c'est pas un problème de rejeter le
présent c'est que je crois que si vous
voulez aujourd'hui on se sert de la
culture pop on se sert des années 60
mais les gens qui se servent des années
60 font des rond des vies qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ça et donc voilà on produit
on produit de la de la culture qui est
souvent une une comment dire c'est du
maquillage oui c'est pas la semaine mais
on sent tout de même mais on sent tout
bon d'abord il y a une méditation sur le
vieillissement la déchéance mais on sent
tout de même que cette époque le défrise
parce qu'il a la nostalgie de la liberté
des années 70 de la liberté sexuelle de
la liberté de ce défoncer de les enfin
bref et que le il y a quelque chose dans
moderne
qui qui ne lui va plus qui ne lui va pas
il lui paraît peut-être trop corseté
trop puritaine que sais-je même si par
ailleurs c'est quand même on pourrait
lui objecter que tu n'es pas moi que le
la lutte contre la pédophile ou pour le
consentement en matière d'amour tout ça
ce sont des progrès mais lui on sent que
c'est pas c'est pas sombre il est pas
dans son temps moi le progrès je vous
avouerai je m'en fous un peu pardon et
par ailleurs je crois que c'est un
problème esthétique surtout c'est à dire
qu'en fait son problème c'est pas du
tout un problème moral moi j'ai jamais
me suis jamais trop posé la question et
je dis je parce que là c'est c'est
l'auteur qui parle je me pose pas la
question je j'écris ce que je peux le
problème qu'on rencontre c'est que je
crois qu'en effet on produit des choses
aujourd'hui parfois et je parle
notamment dans l'audiovisuel qui sont à
quelques exceptions près remarquables
parfois qui sont des des produits on va
dire dérivés quoi et parce que en fait
il y a eu il y a eu le produit qui était
les Stones en 60 et puis après on
fabrique du on fabrique de la du truc à
la chaîne et lui il se retrouve dans
cette chaîne tout simplement parce que
littéralement il arrive plus à écrire et
on pourrait dire aussi économiquement il
n'arrive pas à survivre donc il prend il
prend ce qu'on lui donne et donc il
écrit pour pour
la maison de production n'est pas cités
mais enfin voilà pour donc c'est une
situation économique c'est une situation
après sur le sur le côté moralisateur
etc je crois qu'il s'en fout en fait
c'est moi je m'en fous personnellement
mon problème mais pas de donner des
leçons je trouve pas que l'écrivain a
donné des leçons particulières et quand
j'ai écrit le livre sur Eva j'ai pas
pris position sur les sur les histoires
ou à peine mais c'était pas c'était pas
le but c'était le but c'était de faire
une oeuvre et de faire quelque chose qui
est qui est une voilà qui est une
structure qui est un air quoi voilà
c'est ça qui pour moi compte
Simon Libérati performance cette ce goût
que vous avez
de l'esthétique à au moins ça de bien
c'est que vous avez une écriture assez
classique on sent que vous êtes beaucoup
plus inspiré par le 18e le 19e siècle
par le nouveau roman en tout cas c'est
un livre drôle souvent triste parfois
bien écrit performance aux éditions
Grasset
Emma Becker la conduite alors vous vous
n'y allez pas avec le dos de la cuillère
donc c'est le récit d'une jeune femme à
Berlin qui pour 10 se distraire de la
responsabilité écrasante ou en tout cas
de la présence envahissante d'un jeune
enfant dont elle qu'elle vient d'avoir
multiplie les aventures un peu
sentimentales plutôt érotique je peux
pas faire la liste complète je la fais
de mémoire mais il y a un chômeur
anglais il y a un trader américain il y
a un russe de passage dans un parc il y
a un ancien amant à elle qui est un
chirurgien il y a un réalisateur
français qui de la drague de manière
éhontée mais qui à la fin se dérobe et a
peur et n'y va pas bon bref c'est très
très bien écrit je dois dire c'est
souvent drôle
et puis ça permet de rentrer dans les
arcanes du désir ou du plaisir au
féminin ou en tout cas du vôtre
dans votre cerveau et je dois dire que
parfois on en est effrayé est-ce l'effet
de votre génération des chutes des sites
pour nous libres ou que sais-je mais on
a l'impression que le sexe la sexualité
en général et les hommes en particulier
sont un pur objet de consommation
chez l’impression que les hommes soient
plus un objet de consommation pour moi
que les femmes le sont pour les hommes
en général c'est simplement que j'ai eu
dans ma vie très tôt un certain appétit
pour les hommes que j'essaye de que
j'essaye de questionner parce que je me
demande si c'est un goût à moi ou si
c'est un goût acquis quelque chose que
j'ai métabolisé sans vraiment y penser
et je crois que ce qui m'intéresse n'est
pas en fait je crois que ce sont plutôt
des aventures sentimentales que
sexuelles réellement c'est à dire que je
pense que la sexualité au bout d'un
moment
révèle beaucoup d'une personne et je
pense que si ça se passe bien avec une
personne au lit alors il y a peut-être
une chance que ça se passe bien dans
dans la vie quotidienne je pense que
j'ai pris ce pli
d'aller d'abord au lit pour voir comment
ça se passait après mais j'essaye pas de
me distraire de la présence de mon fils
j'essaie de me distraire de la façon
dont la maternité est organisée pour les
femmes dans ce dans ce monde-là et qui
me semble d'une injustice totale et
voilà j'essaie de m'en distraire avec la
seule ivresse que je connais c'est qui
me satisface et qui est finalement les
hommes je reviens à un instant c'est une
chose que je trouve que il y a plusieurs
reprises en livre on comprend que
la façon dont vous abordez les rapports
avec les hommes sont une manière aussi
d'échapper à leur ascendant de prendre
l'ascendant sur Meski curieux c'est que
vous les soumettez en vous soumettant à
eux ce qui est étrange et c'est ça qui
vous a valu les réprimantes des d'un
certain de certaines féministe c'est que
vous vous oui c'est ça pour les
soumettre vous vous soumettez on dirait
que le seul plaisir que vous prenez et
celui que vous leur donnez ce qui est
assez paradoxal non mais c'est paradoxal
on fera enfin non pas vraiment je pense
que pour les femmes qui ont grandi dans
mon monde et dans cette génération là la
sexualité c'est un peu la seule arme
qu'on a laissé aux femmes enfin on m'a
bien fait comprendre depuis que je suis
toute petite que finalement il y avait
une arme qui marchait pour soumettre les
hommes et pour faire sa place dans ce
monde un petit peu notre cul quand même
j'essaye de mon j'essaye de m'en
remettre bien sûr on a d'autres on a
d'autres armes mais c'est vrai que j'ai
souvent j'ai longtemps vécu avec ce
principe en tête qu'avec le pouvoir de
la sexualité finalement tous les hommes
étaient potentiellement soumettable
submissibles je sais pas quoi ce qu'on
dit sous mes tables j'aime bien
donc donc voilà c'est aussi
effectivement ce rapport là que
j'interroge et ce que quand je désire un
homme c'est vraiment cet homme que je
désire ou est-ce que c'est l'état dans
lequel je le mets est-ce que c'est
l'état dans lequel on se met
réciproquement c'est une réflexion que
j'essaye de faire sur sur ce désir qu'on
a les uns pour les autres alors on a
l'impression que je me trompe
complètement mais on a l'impression que
et d'ailleurs c'est une configuration
assez classique on voit ça chez standard
par exemple qui a une distinction
complète entre le cœur et le corps c'est
à dire qu'on a l'impression que vous
n'aimez pas vous ne pouvez pas aimer les
gens avec qui vous couchez et
en revanche celui qui se dérobe à vous
le seul qui refuse de coucher avec vous
Vincent alors là tout à coup votre coeur
palpite pour lui comme si il fallait
qu'on vous résiste pour attirer votre
vous vous votre affection amoureuse vous
n'êtes pas tout à fait juste non non
c'est pas vrai on c'est le truc c'est
qu'avec Vincent on s'écrit pendant très
longtemps et donc l'écriture moi ça
c'est quelque chose qui me fait tomber
amoureuse enfin le la correspondance est
quelque chose qui me fait tomber
amoureuse mais j'ai quand même le
prochain le projet de coucher avec lui
donc mais mais j'ai ce j'ai cet espoir
qu'en couchant ensemble justement
l'histoire d'amour va s'arrêter parce
que je vais être déçu parce que vous
avez raison il y a cette division entre
le corps et la tête et c'est vrai que
c'est aussi quelque chose que j'essaye
de réconcilier
parce que il me semble que c'est très
compliqué de s'abandonner enfin moi en
tant que femme j'ai toujours trouvé ça
très compliqué de n'être plus qu'un
corps qui sent et qui réagit aux
caresses j'ai toujours tendance à être
un petit peu en retrait parce que
pendant très longtemps ce qui m'a
importé bien plus que mon plaisir de mon
désir c'était ce des hommes et je vous
disais tout à l'heure oui oui non mais
vous avez tout à fait raison mais les
raisons qui m'ont je pense que c'est un
long formatage qui date depuis
pratiquement mes petit enfant qui est
imposé par le monde dans lequel je vis
et puis il faut pas oublier non plus
qu'en écrivant ce livre je sors de 3 ans
au bordel et que quelque part d'avoir
vécu pendant trois ans avec le désir des
hommes comme fonds de commerce ça
implique que du coup on ne couche pas
avec les hommes de la même façon après
parce qu'il y a toute cette partie de
vous qu'il faut que vous rééduquiez à
sentir mais je reviens sur ce point
pardonnez-moi avec insistance quand on
lit votre lit on a l'impression qu'il y
a au fond que votre vie en tout cas la
vie donc on a ratrice se résume à deux
éléments le sexe et l'écriture le sexe
d'ailleurs pour nourrir l'écriture et
l'écriture pour parler du sexe
la chair est triste c'est là c'est je ne
fais qu'écrire des livres mais mais en
même temps du coup il y a on a
l'impression que la sexualité qui est
extraordinairement suivante
sans arrêt décrite sont du tout qui est
des routismes c'est pas naïsme
très précisément décrite et comme des
réaliser au fond vous venez de le dire
vous avez été élevé pour une certaine
façon de donner du plaisir enfin on a
l'impression que le sexe est à la fois
très présent et complètement
absent en réalité enfin des réaliser des
incarnés
c'est possible parce que j'écris pas
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu dire de
moi que j'étais un auteur érotique c'est
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure Simon
sur les cases dans lesquelles on vous
met moi je sors mon premier bouquin
monsieur j'ai pas l'impression d'écrire
un livre érotique mais de fait il y a
des scènes qui le sont parce que c'est
une histoire d'amour moi j'ai pas
l'impression de faire de l'érotisme dans
le sens où je ne cherche pas à
émoustiller mon lecteur moi ce qui
m'intéresse dans la description des
scènes sexuelles c'est bien à quel
moment la rencontre s'est faite ou ne
s'est pas faite j'essaye de mettre en
recul dans une scène que j'ai déjà vécu
pour essayer de comprendre ce qui a
marché ce qui a pas marché pour essayer
de me mettre à la place de la personne
avec qui j'étais pour revivre aussi la
scène donc il y a une tentative de
revivre des scènes et en ce sens le sexe
n'est pas totalement désincarné mais
c'est vrai que j'en fais une analyse qui
est qui n'a pas pour pour but
d'émoustiller lecteurs au tout début du
livre le livre commence sur le fait que
vous accompagniez votre grand-père dans
ces derniers moments un grand père qui
vous a reproché votre inconduite
un repas un grand-père devant lequel
vous avez eu honte et et finalement vous
vous dans dans le livre où vous repentez
en quelque sorte du tort que vous lui
avez fait dans une déclaration d'amour
que vous lui faites
on se dit en lisant ça au début du livre
qu'il a fallu que cette figure du code
de ces statuts du Commandeur que ce sur
moi comme dirait un psychanalyste que
cette exprès de cette incarnation d'un
certain point de vue moral disparaisse
pour que vous vous sentiez libre de
conduire la vie qui a été la vôtre et de
l'écrire oui c'est vrai que quand
souvent quand j'écris des livres j'ai
toujours au bout d'un moment cette cette
idée de qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
papounet va en penser qu'est-ce que mon
père va en penser qu'est-ce que mes
parents vont penser votre enfant
qu'est-ce que j'y suis pas encore mais
vous avez raison on va y arriver à un
moment ça m'a jamais vraiment empêché
d'écrire mais je crois qu'effectivement
il faut au bout d'un moment soit tuer
ses parents soit qui meurent de même et
c'est vrai que
[Musique]
c'est vrai que mon grand-père a été une
figure paternelle très très importante
et devant laquelle j'avais souvent
effectivement des des scrupules à
décrire le sexe de la façon qui me
semblait la plus cru c'est à dire la
plus juste la plus honnête et peut-être
que ce livre là est plus cru que les
autres parce que je n'ai pas eu les
mêmes je n'avais pas la même ombre dans
mon épaule la conduite c'est le titre de
votre livre alors évidemment
l'inconduite c'est vos comportements
condamnables par la morale commune mais
le rédacteur en chef de cette émission
me faisait observer que ça pourrait être
aussi un adjectif qui s'applique à vous
vous êtes une femme inconduite une femme
qu'on ne peut pas conduire à une femme
qu'on ne peut pas diriger est-ce que au
fond
l'ensemble de ce que vous écrivez
dont ce dernier ouvrage c'est une espèce
de
manifeste pour la liberté pour le refus
de l'ordre pour le refus de la loi dont
le sexe n'est qu'au fond l'un des
visages
je sais pas du tout d'être dans la
transgression j'écris les choses que
j'ai envie d'écrire parce qu'il me
semble qu'elles sont importantes et je
trouve à chaque instant de ma vie des
moments qui sont poignants et dont je
pense qu'ils sont riches en enseignement
pour moi comme pour les gens qui me
lisent le côté sulfureux c'est pas moi
qui me qui me le revendique c'est
quelque chose qu'on m'a mis sur sur le
dos quand j'ai sorti mon premier bouquin
et auquel j'essaye de
je fais cavalier seul j'ai je m'occupe
pas de ça mais c'est vrai que c'est une
étiquette qui me colle à la peau mais je
pense que c'est peut-être parce que je
parle de sexe et que c'est toujours plus
compliqué pour une femme d'en parler que
pour un homme parce qu'on considère que
c'est une dynamique normale de la vie
d'un homme et pour une femme c'est
toujours un peu particulier donc
non je continue mon petit bonhomme de
chemin
sans ce besoin d'étiquette
merci la conduite aux éditions Albin
Michelet nous n'avons pas tout à fait
fini nous allons rejoindre une lectrice
parce que le bonheur des livres c'est
d'abord le plaisir des lecteurs Salomé
Suarez qui va je crois poser une
question à Simon libératis Salomé on
vous écoute
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Salomé j'ai 28 ans
et j'habite à Paris la littérature pour
moi c'est une affaire de famille on se
transmet l'amour du verbe et des mots de
génération en génération et c'est
surtout une affaire de femmes parce que
ma grand-mère les a énormément ma mère
avant moi et moi aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler aujourd'hui de d'un roman
que j'ai adoré et qui est sorti il y a
quelques semaines chez Gallimard Clara
luproust de Stéphane carrier Clara
lubrouste c'est un roman plein d'espoir
qui fait du bien dans cette rentrée
littéraire assez brumeuse je trouve
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune femme de 20
ans qui est coiffeuse et qui va
complètement par hasard se mettre à lire
Proust et qui va complètement
bouleverser sa vie c'est un très beau
livre sur le pouvoir des mots et le
pouvoir de ses livres qui changent
complètement le destin d'une personne
ma question aujourd'hui pour Simon
Liberati est la suivante vous écrivez un
livre avec pour toile de fond les
Rolling Stones et je me suis demandé en
refermant le roman quel bande originale
qu'elle bande-son vous auriez choisi
pour définir tout l'univers de votre de
votre super roman
alors Simon libératif la bande-son c'est
quoi ces Sticky Fingers non ça serait un
morceau qui est postérieur à la olive
qui est sympathie for the devil que j'ai
toujours beaucoup aimé à cause des cœurs
dans lequel d'ailleurs je crois qu'un
État palenberg fait des AA et voilà donc
j'aime bien ce morceau je l'écoute
toujours il y a un beau film de Godard
que je vous conseille qui s'appelle One
Plus One oui à la répétition des et on
voit Brian Jones à la fin complètement
des faits c'est un beau un beau film
merci cette émission touche à sa fin
mais elle n'est pas complètement finie
parce que nous avons de nous quitter on
va vous recommander des lectures et on
va commencer d'ailleurs par vous
Emma et Simon mais attention vous devez
recommander un livre satisfait ou
remboursé c'est à dire que vous ne devez
pas vous tromper dans les dans les choix
que vous proposez
à ceux qui nous suivent sinon vous serez
poursuivi pendant 20 dicte commence par
vous ciment quel est le livre que vous
recommandez le livre que je lis le plus
en ce moment je lis tous les matins et
c'est le journal inutile de Paul Morand
c'est un livre qui est sorti chez
Gallimard il y a déjà plus de 20 ans
c'est un des meilleurs livres par une
puis bien longtemps et c'est un livre
qui est déjà ancien puisque le journal a
été terminé en 76 et c'est ce que je lis
tous les matins depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois voilà je suis un lecteur
assidu de ce livre j'ai lu deux fois
déjà Emma quels sont Emma Becker quel
est votre recommandation de la semaine
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup aimé les enfants
endormis d'Anthony Passeron aux édition
du globe qui est un bouquin où il
revient en fait sur une histoire de
famille sur son oncle qui est mort du
sida qui était héroïne nomade et c'était
vraiment le la découverte de de ce virus
à l'époque et il alterne justement les
souvenirs de de la vie de cet homme et
les découvertes que les médecins font à
cette à ce moment-là et c'est vraiment
un livre bouleversant merci quant à moi
enfin quant à nous je veux dire
l'émission nous vous recommandons la
biographie en poche de Miles Davis par
Franck Medioni donc Miles Davis
probablement le premier jazzman a donné
une rockstar c'est la Dias fusion et
médiioni est un excellent journaliste de
jazz il a il a fait d'autres biographies
Charlie Parker Martial Solal et voilà
c'est un très bon livre ça c'est pour
vous et pour la bande son de votre
prochain livre super Laurent Saïd
Ghislaine Maxwell je ne l'ai pas lu
l'enseigne mettez la a été pendant des
années correspondante aux États-Unis
chaîne de télévision et là elle fait
elle refait le parcours de de la fille
de Maxwell qui a connu donc deux
aventures épouvantables dans sa vie son
père et son amant elle est aujourd'hui
pour poursuivie dans le cas de cette
affaire
ça vous intéresse c'est pour vous
excellent livre Céline Nassim c'est un
ancien journaliste de Libération et
c'est la vie la traversée du chaos
libanais
à travers le regard d'un personnage
c'est un livre très très bien écrit
passionnant
donc c'est pas preneur vous êtes trop
pris par Paul Morand c'est ça
et puis recherche une bande dessinée
mais oui je vous le donne vous allez
voir ça va vous changer et puis Rochette
c'est une bande dessinée recette il
avait fait des bandes dessinées assez
assez immoral genre chrome mais là il
revient avec un album animalier très
beau je vous le recommande vivement
voilà au bonheur des livres s'achève
mais pour vous le temps de la lecture
commence merci Simon merci Emma merci à
notre lectrice Salomée et merci à vous
tous qui nous avait écouté vous pouvez
revoir cette émission sur le site de
Public Sénat ou bien en podcast sur
votre plateforme préférée et sinon nous
nous retrouvons la semaine prochaine
même chaîne même heure à moins que d'ici
là nous ne nous soyons croisés dans une
librairie bonsoir
[Musique]